[Music]
for more than a year have reached the
top of Mount Everest together Adrian
Ballinger and Cory Richards attempted to
climb last year but only Richards was
able to finish after a final push that
took nearly 12 hours they both made it
to the summit over the weekend Everest
is of course the highest point on earth
at an elevation of more than 29,000 feet
the Ballinger was able to match a
special achievement that his friend
recorded in last year's climb Dana
Jacobson followed them as they shared
their journey on snapchat Dana good
morning good morning this year both Cory
and Adrian reached the world's highest
peak but it was Adrian who accomplished
their ultimate goal of making it without
supplemental oxygen the grueling summit
push took more than 40 hours round trip
the highs and lows of it all shared with
the world on social media their bodies
pushed to the limit Cory and Adrian
spent less than 15 minutes on top of
Mount Everest taking in a view few
others have seen while both climbers
made it to the top only Adrian did it
without supplemental oxygen there's a
dream right there the summit is just
through the clouds on his way down Cory
met a group of climbers who supplied him
with supplemental oxygen the oxygen gave
Cory the energy to reach the summit
first from there he cheered on his
friend as he made the final push in 37
days
Adrian logged nearly 140 miles while
acclimating to the high altitude he
consumed just under 23 thousand calories
on a special diet that allowed him to
breathe air comprised of less than eight
percent oxygen safely back at advanced
base camp Adrian reflected on the
experience feels super emotional I cried
so hard yesterday on the summit in the
last 10 meters to the summit and in the
20 meters off the summit
I would never will climb Everest without
oxygen again and I am so proud and happy
he said Korey support in the final
minutes of his ascent gave him the
energy he needed it was just so amazing
to be up there with core we did together
as always planned so a fitting ending
definitely fitting adrian joins Korey
and a select group of less than 200
others who have scaled Mount Everest
without supplemental oxygen the Eddie
Bauer alpinists are now off the mountain
they're making their way back to the US
and they're gonna join us here on set to
tell us about their experience early
next week it was such a team effort when
I tell you that it came down to who was
giving the oxygen to Korey later Adrien
being on the headphones basically saying
on the walkie-talkie
please Korey use the oxygen and come and
help me so it was an amazing team well
when they come visit us we have lots of
oxygen amazing you said you never
doubted they would make it out wondering
I did I just knew that they wanted to
achieve what they have achieved together
yeah it's so great can't wait for them
to come back thanks Danny thank you